[Musique]
c'est une information révélée par rtl
selon laquelle sylvie tellier la
présidente du comité miss france serait
écarté de la présentation du concours 1
apparaîtra en fait qu'au début et à la
fin au moment tout simplement du sacre
de la nouvelle miss il faut dire que
depuis quelques années l'ancien mise
prenait de plus en plus de place aux
côtés de jean pierre foucault jusqu'à
être présente à ses côtés tout au long
des dernières cérémonies et alors une
présence qui avait été critiquée par de
nombreux téléspectateurs sur les réseaux
sociaux sans compter que sylvie tellier
s'est retrouvé récemment au coeur d'une
polémique suite à l'exclusion danel bien
big miss guadeloupe en raison de photos
dénudées accepte la décision c'est là
sylvie tellier ne sera désormais
présente qu'au début et à la fin du
programme
autre décision majeure c'est alexia
laroche joubert qui s'occupera à présent
de la direction artistique du concours
d'une mise à l'écart soudaine de sylvie
tellier qui interroge alors sylvie
tellier évincé de l'animation de miss
france choqués ont pas choquer qui dit
miss france dit marquez qui démarque est
dit nathalie nathalie dit jean-pierre
alors excusez moi mais j'ai eu si vite
ailier hier soir au téléphone parce que
justement met en place en ce moment pour
faire parce que ça va être le centenaire
des miss france donc on va réunir toutes
les nuits il en reste des miss france on
perd ou pas
bonjour est ce compliqué et donc je les
jolies au téléphone et puis justement
bien ça tombe bien parce que gérard des
questions sur elle dément absolument
c'est une rumeur encore à la con qu'il
faut arrêter ça tout ça parce que ça
c'est drôle c'est faux c'est une rumeur
sans doute pour des repérages et elle
prépare une superbe émission avec plein
d'invités plein sur envolé pour la
france et ça va être une émission au top
je suis désolé de vous décevoir
c'est pas vrai jean va pas non et
heureusement vous attendez c'est le
pilier pour moi ce chèque on a démenti
on va pas avancer
ouais recul et c'est normal